in Malang this is a community in
mourning and shock seventeen-year-old
wedad went to a football match his
family never expected that he wouldn't
make it home
the game turned to tragedy after police
fired tear gas at Spectators apparently
to control fans who entered the field
after the match ended
people panicked triggering a stampede as
they rushed to the gates
Rehan zelani survived but his friend
didn't
you know police through tear gas to the
lower part of the stadium I saw children
dying in front of my eyes people were
scattering around in panic trying to
escape but the exits were locked so they
were piling up their hundreds were
injured in the chaos Witnesses paint a
horrific picture
as people ran towards the exit it was
locked and then the lights dimmed in the
stadium it was dark people were pushing
each other and even stepping over each
other trying to get out this is the
waiting area of the saiful Anwar
Hospital in Malang one of the hospitals
close to the stadium most of the people
waiting here are parents waiting
anxiously for updates on their children
seventeen-year-old rafana DUI afrancia
is in the Intensive Care Unit
I was staying up waiting for him it was
so late and he hadn't come home everyone
else in our neighborhood who had been to
the match had started to come home where
was my son
as she worries about her son she Ponders
why he ended up in hospital in the first
place
why did police gas them there were many
children up there and mothers too now
you see who the victims are many of them
are just young boys like my son
putri's mother is also waiting for an
update from the ICU
her face was swollen and the bones in
her neck dislocated she's unconscious
Indonesia's president has asked for an
investigation and human rights groups
are calling for answers and
accountability criticizing police for
using tear gas in a confined space
for now many of the parents who spoke to
Al Jazeera say the only question on
their mind is whether their child will
make it through Jessica Washington Al
Jazeera Malang